Deadpool in the M see you something that
we've all been wanting for an extremely
long time now since we first saw the
first Deadpool movie the one with Ryan
Reynolds at least or the one where Ryan
Reynolds's mouth wasn't glued shut
is that you
[Music]
hey it's me don't scratch just cleaning
up the timelines and it's been a long
time since we've heard anything official
related to Deadpool entering the MCU but
today we have something official from
Ryan Reynolds himself and another person
at Marvel as well and not to mention we
finally have an update on whether or not
Deadpool is going to remain rated R in
the MCU or if he's going to be pg-13 so
let's break down all the latest news
quick reminder if you'd like a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel leave a like and
a comment down below to enter my
giveaway so today in true Ryan Reynolds
fashion ryan revealed through social
media which is something that he likes
to do throw out leaks through social
media he revealed that yesterday he was
at Marvel Studios Ryan posted this
picture to social media with the caption
auditioned for the role of Anthony Stark
didn't come even remotely close but the
nice man with the Taser escorted me to
the ground
now obviously he's kidding but he does
revealed that he was indeed at Marvel
Studios does this mean that an
announcement for Deadpool 3 is coming
soon now this is not the first time that
Ryan Reynolds has teased Deadpool in the
MCU not too long ago he posted another
photo on social media with a caption
investigation heading into year 5 or as
I call it phase 5 the point is I love
conspiracy yarn so this was our first
hint that we could be getting the next
Deadpool movie in phase 5 of the MCU
phase 4 has obviously all been revealed
all of the movies and the Disney
plushies that are coming as well but as
far as phase 5 is concerned we don't
know too much about what is coming but
Ryan Reynolds has teased Deadpool coming
in phase 5 and yesterday he did meet
with somebody at Marvel Studios most
likely Kevin Feige and we also know that
the key creative team at Marvel Studios
does a creative retreat once a year and
that is either happened already or is
going to be happening pretty soon and
Deadpool is most likely going to be one
of the characters that is majorly
discussed remember at San Diego
comic-con Kevin Feige said that the
mutants were coming and then in an
interview directly after he said that
Deadpool is grouped in there
the mutants and it has recently been
confirmed by the writers of Deadpool
that Deadpool will indeed remain rated-r
yesterday in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Paul Wernick told
them Marvel has promised to continue to
let us play in the r-rated Deadpool
universe and the hope is that they will
also let us veer into the MCU a little
bit as well and play in that sandbox so
for those of you who were concerned
Deadpool is going to remain rated R but
most likely just for his solo films
don't expect Deadpool to be rated R if
he appears in a spider-man film or an
Avengers film if they ever bring him
into a team movie he's definitely going
to be pg-13 but that in itself is a
great opportunity for breaking the
fourth wall you can just imagine
Deadpool looking into the camera saying
oh I'm in a film with spider-man I can't
use big boy words so even though it's
pg-13 there's still a lot of opportunity
for a lot of comedy there so all of this
is coming to light kind of at the same
time Deadpool is confirmed to be
remaining rated R and Ryan Reynolds just
had a meeting at Marvel Studios it seems
like a Deadpool announcement could be
happening relatively sooner than we
thought especially if we consider the
fact that Ryan Reynolds has teased
Deadpool entering the MCU in phase 5 but
really the big news is that Ryan
Reynolds has met with Marvel Studios to
talk about Deadpool
so let me know your thoughts when do you
think we're going to get Deadpool in the
MCU do you think Ryan Reynolds is
leaving us clues and are you excited
that Deadpool is a remaining rated R let
me know all your thoughts in the
comments down below and of course don't
forget to subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway as well and just be sure to
drop a like and a comment below I'm
starting a giveaway within a week on
Twitter and Instagram as well so be sure
to follow me on there and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof